winter has come and gone and now it's
time to go back to the golden age of one
of the most ancient and powerful
families in westeros with a new trailer
giving us our first glimpse at the
prequel series let's dig into the small
details you missed in the house of the
dragon teaser trailer elsa the dragon is
exciting for a whole myriad of reasons
but for many game of thrones fans
getting to see the ancestral home of the
targaryens once again is certainly a
highlight this teaser trailer gives us
plenty of looks into dragonstone a
castle standing upon the eponymous
island in blackwater bay during most of
game of thrones it was home to stannis
baratheon where he ruled his lord until
his death in season 5. in season 7 the
mother of dragons herself daenerys
returns to dragonstone her birth place
where she intends to launch her battle
for the iron throne but dragonstone is
never seen in its original splendor
during game of thrones
i was born a dragonstone
not that i can remember it
we imagine we'll get to see even more of
the valyrian artistry at dragonstone
demonstrating just how powerful and
wealthy the targaryens were before the
iron throne fell
the first trailer for house of the
dragon is short but there's plenty in
the teaser to get excited about
including the first sighting of the hand
of the king even if it's literally just
a shot of the man's hand and pin
all game of thrones fans are well aware
of how badly things can go for someone
in this position with tyrion lannister
and davos seaworth the only two to
survive throughout the series in house
of the dragon this role will be filled
by the character otto hightower played
by rhys ephons who is perhaps best known
for playing the lizard in the amazing
spider-man according to hbo's official
character description hightower loyally
and faithfully serves both his king and
his realm but he greatly dislikes the
king's brother who he sees as the
greatest threat to the kingdom of course
like ned stark this instinct and intense
concern could easily lead to his death
because although he is the hand of the
king we all know how hard it is to stop
a targaryen from getting what they want
one of the most intriguing shots in the
trailer shows off paddy considine's king
viserys the first targaryen sitting on
the iron throne clutching a pretty
unique sword the weapon in question is
actually the blackfyre sword made out of
valyrian steel not only does this make
it incredibly strong but anyone who
watched game of thrones knows that it is
also one of the few materials in the
world that can kill white walkers the
blackfyre sword is the ancestral blade
of the house although it's worth knowing
that house blackfyre is a separate cadet
house built out of house targaryen and
they fought against their own family a
number of times over the years it's
entirely possible that the show might
include the blackfyre rebellion however
house of the dragon is building up to
the main targaryen civil war which
eventually spells doom for the family
known as dance of the dragons it seems
likely that the blackfyre sword will
cause plenty of infighting depending on
who wields it
the trailer gives fans a glimpse of the
iron throne during a banquet scene
involving the targaryens and house
valerian but a later shot reveals that
it has a vastly different look in the
spin-off series the last shot of the
trailer shows a mysterious white-haired
person strolling towards the iron throne
and the red keeps great hull but it's
much bigger than fans of the main series
were expecting it stretches outwards on
both sides with a sea of swords
extending down the steps and spreading
further into the hull the iron throne
was originally forged by aegon the
conqueror who used his dragon to melt
200 swords together before it was shaped
into the iconic seat of power
in a blink and you'll miss it moment 42
seconds into the teaser we catch a
glimpse of an image any game of thrones
fan would be able to identify in their
sleep the wolf of the stark sigil during
the scenes at the joust the stark banner
can be seen as a horse carrying a rider
gallops past however the starks aren't
the only family represented in those
scenes in another shot you can clearly
see the familiar banners of house tarly
which feature a red huntsman on a green
background their size and placement
leads us to believe the tarlies are
likely hosting the joust and we quickly
see a member of the family participating
against a member of what appears to be
house cole the lion sigil for house
lannister is also seen as is a banner
featuring a golden sunburst on a blue
background though it doesn't seem to be
as easily identifiable as the others it
could be a forerunner of house of tarp
it's clear based on what we've seen that
the house sigils have changed and
evolved over time as they don't all
match up perfectly with the versions
that appeared in game of thrones which
takes place 200 years after the events
of house of the dragon the changes are
small but they're a smart way to signify
we're not in the same version of
westeros
near the end the teaser trailer provides
fans with the first major look at
actress olivia cook as alison hightower
and it's safe to say that she does not
look happy alison is the daughter of the
hand of the king described by hbo as the
most comely woman in the seven kingdoms
in the short clip shown in the house of
the dragon teaser alicent appears to be
distraught running through what is
likely one of the main meeting rooms of
the castle wielding a dagger with a ruby
in the hilt with little to go off of
it's hard to guess exactly what's going
on here but clearly that knife is going
to come into play in the series one way
or the other check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite television
shows are coming soon subscribe to our
youtube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]
you